>From the documentation,
we want single choiceMode
so that the list item only shows
one selected item at a time.
We can declare this attribute
on the ListView
in the fragment_main file.
However, we don't want to specify
choiceMode in one pane mode.
To have these different code paths,
we could copy the file
in the Layout folder
and put it in the Layout-sw600dp folder.
A better solution is to declare a style,
so we have one layout file
but different styles.
In the Base styles file
in the Values folder,
we declare ForecastListStyle.
We leave it empty because we don't need
to specify choiceMode.
We create a new styles file
in the values-sw600dp folder.
In the two-pane case,
the ForecastListStyle
does include the choiceMode.
The two files have a different
number of styles.
If it's not declared a higher folder,
then it will just fall back
to the Base style.